puis dire déjà on va les premières fois
valentina alors vous faites le sampler à
ma place
d'ailleurs alors c'est la première fois
qu'on se voit on va faire une atonie
première fois vous vous souvenez de
votre premier noël
non bonsoir je soulevais de votre
première objet fétiche
non ça lui manque d'audace est ce que
vous vous souvenez de votre premier pc à
sarry c'était quoi est-ce que c'est
notre première mi temps c'était bien
aller le premier amour c'était tout de
suite bien ah oui c'était d'accord donc
j'ai pas besoin de demander le premier
flirt le premier baiser le premier homme
parce que dès le premier amour c'était
réglé
ah ouais la priver un mot c'était le bon
vous en garder un bon souvenir à trèbes
à samadet pour après elle est sexy c'est
devant tina
pauli de moitié serge on peut pas
mosaïque et thierry loin vous êtes sûr
thierry lake erie mais c'est un échec
pour les modalités cherché à échapper à
la mosaïque mais comme ça que je vais
comme ça ce moment commence à voir avec
plaisir les jours que tu sois là
moi je dis qu'on est beaucoup mieux ici
alors mesdames messieurs s'il ya de
l'air qui sort la casse est donc en mai
bien là et bien là
alors que les messieurs on va voir
maintenant